[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émissionù on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
mais aussi politique et nous recevons
cette semaine un invité exceptionnel
Jean-Pierre Dar bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et avec
moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Jean-Pierre
d'oussin bonjour vous êtes acteur et
réalisateur vous êtes pour nous tous un
visage très connu du cinéma français
depuis les années 90 que l'on associe à
Robert guedigan dont vous êtes un des
acteurs fétiches votre filmographie est
immense allons retenons une liste non
exhaustive de mes films préférés alors
mes meilleurs copains cuisine et
dépendance un air de famille qui vous
vaut le prix du meilleur acteur dans un
second rôle Marius et Jeanette le cœur
des hommes ou encore cette excellente
série télévisé le bureau des légendes où
vous campez le personnage d'Henry Duflot
Socrate aux cravates franchement moches
on peut le dire alors on peut vous voir
actuellement au cinéma dans le théorème
de Marguerite d'Anna Novion et dans et
la fête continue toujours auertgiguan
ainsi qu'au théâtre dans le principe
d'incertitude mise en scène par luido de
langanin par votre carrière vous
incarnez le cinéma hexagonal et c'est
donc sans surprise que vous nous avez
demandé pour ce déjeuner une valeur sûre
de la cuisine française ah bah oui pard
une blanquette de veau et en dessert
c'est un peu plus exotique une Pavlova
au
mangue dans le dessous des plats
connaissez-vous la vraie l'authentique
bouillabaise Clément perau est allé la
déguster pour nous sur le petit port des
Goudes à Marseille dans les pieds d'
plat avec l'inflation la précarité
alimentaire augmente les restaurants du
corp sont débordés obligés de ref fusée
du monde reportage à suivre allez on
passe à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence Jean-Pierre Daroussin pour
deviner votre plat j'ai commencé par
décortiquer votre filmographie où il y a
vraiment à boire et à manger j'ai bien
compris que vous alliez faire l'impasse
sur la viande de porc car de bon matin
visiblement le cri du cochon vous
effraie surtout lorsqu'il résonne dans
cuisine et dépendance j'ai aimis
l'hypothèse du poulpe que Brigitte j'ai
vite abandonné car même préparé par le
grand restaurant dans l'eau froide avec
le cactus ça reste difficilement
comestible vous allez me rétorquer c'est
le goût des autres en tous les cas ce
n'est pas le mien j'ai vaguement imaginé
un clin d'œil de votre part avec un gras
double vous qui avez dirigé une armada
d'agent double dans le bureau des
légendes mais ayant donc fait chou blanc
avec la grande famille du cinéma je me
suis rabattu sur la famille tout court
et là je suis tombé sur un moment de
vérité une séquence émotion qui n'était
pas du syoche sur France Culture un
hommage à votre maman et surtout à sa
blanquette de veau de compè avec des
pommes de terre et de la crème on vous a
donc préparé une blanquette sera-t-elle
à la hauteur vous allez nous le dire on
a le droit de manger bien sûr on a pas
non seulement le droit mais on a
l'obligation de manger on va même la
goûter ensemble si vous le voulez bien
avec grand plaisir oui c'est vrai que
c'est un hommage à à ma maman euh
euh c'était le le plat que tout le monde
lui
réclamait voilà le réussissait et quand
quand on avait quand on mangeait une
blanquette de veau à la maison il y
avait le silence à table silence absolu
silence absolu à table et c'était
remarquable quo parce qu' au bout d'un
moment on se rendait compte que personne
ne parlait alors que d'habitude les les
repas étaient plutôt animés voilà alors
on va pas vous faire l'offense de vous
demander si elle est aussi bonne que
celle de de votre maman bien sûr mais
est-ce qu'elle vous rappelle néanmoins
quelques souvenir d'enfance
est pas mal du tout oui alors votre
maman mettait des pommes de terre ou et
c'est d'ailleurs vous parler de ces
pommes de terre comme si c'était des des
bijoux mais j'ai regardé les recettes de
blanquette il y a pas souvent des PC du
riz effectivement oui c'est souvent avec
du riz euh ça arrivait qu'elle le fasse
avec du riz aussi mais c'est vrai que
moi j'aimais bien avec des pommes de
terre vapeur la la blanquette avec des
pommes de terre vapeur avec SAU
pardessus
je je voilà j'ai toujours bien aimé moi
un de mes REP préféré à la à à la maison
c'était tout simplement des des des des
pommes de terre cuites à l'eau avec du
beurre voilà
simple au beurre au sel et voilà céit
j'adorais quand on me faisait ça
j'adorais ça et alors cette blanquette
cette blanquette de veau s'était
réservée pour je sais pas les repas du
dimanche les fêtes de famille ou elle en
faisait régulièrement non c'était
vraiment le repas du dimanche ah oui
donc c'était céit un repas un peu
exceptionnel toute la famille était
autour de la table i euh alors la
famille elle est elle était quand même
assez restreinte on était on était
quatre euh mon père ma ma mère ma sœur
et moi donc c'est une famille tout à
fait restreinte mais bon il y avait pas
beaucoup de place donc ça ça ça ça
faisait quand même
rempli non mais en fait on mangeait pas
tant de viande que ça euh j'ai plutôt eu
la chance de de naître à une époque où
euh où les je dirais que les 15
premières années de ma vie quasiment
entre mes vacances à la campagne et
manger chez moi
moi je suisu d'un milieu ouvrier paysan
donc on était dans une en banlieu mais
dans une petite bicoque de banlieu mais
il y avait un jardin avec un potager
donc comme beaucoup de gens à l'époque
moi j'ai passé toute mon enfance à
manger des produits des produits que que
que que voilà que que que qui était là
qui qui qui poussait là des poireaux des
endives des carottes des il avait des
des
cours c'était votre papa votre maman qui
vous tout le monde s mettait les voisins
aussi les voisins mais parce que c'était
bon il y avait une sorte de jardin
partagé c'était une sorte de jardin
partagé oui et ça faisait vivre
plusieurs familles enfin il y avait
suffisamment pour euh oui on avait il y
avait on était deux
familles sur ce sur ce sur ce petit
ce petit jardin oui mais après
évidemment quand j'étais après quand
j'allais dans la famille en vacances
puisqu'on m'envoyait en vacan à la
campagne dans le Berry quand quand
j'étais quand j'étais gamin tout le
temps régulièrement que ça soit à Noël à
pque pendant les grandes vacances qui à
l'époque durait presque 3 mois vra ça
durait longtemps non c'est pas long en
fait c'est assez logique dans les le
mois de septembre c'est un mois dans les
campagnes où on a besoin vre Mo tout la
récolte tout ça donc on avait besoin de
fallait pas les envoyer à l'école les
les gaminsou on avait besoin qu'il soit
là dans les fermes moi bien sûr
j'ai fait la batteuse jusqu'à l'âge de
jusqu'à 18 ans j'ai fait la batteuse
tout ça j'attendais un patiemment
d'avoir 14 ans pour pouvoir conduire le
tracteur donc c'est NON NON et là c'est
pas alors là là le potager était
beaucoup plus grand mais
oui on mangeait que des produits que des
produits des choses qui sortaient et et
ça c'est un goût c'est une
saveur SAU les pommes de TER parce que
vous racontez dans votre anecdote qu'on
allait les chercher ailleurs il me
semble euh alors oui ça ça c'était à
Courbevoie dans dans dans la banlieue où
j'étais avec mes parents
euh oui mes parents avaient avec
justement les voisins avec qui on avait
le bah les pommes de terre faut quand
même un peu de terrain quoi faut un peu
de terrain on avait pas de temps que ça
et donc le mes parents avaient un plan
pour aller dans la vallée de Chevreuse
dans une une grande ferme où on allait
se faire livrer acheter des des des des
sacs de de de de 50 kg de pommes de
terre et donc vous reveniez avec des des
des sacs de 50 kg de pommes de terre ce
que j'ai retenu dans cet hommage aussi
c'est que vous dites c'était ma ma ma
maman et c'était la vedette quand elle
faisait c'était son or de gloire quand
prépar cette oui oui c'est vrai c'était
je je dois reconnaître que mon père
était celui qui avait un peu la parole à
la maison on était c'est une une
représentation familiale un peu à
l'ancienne très patriarc ma mère est
très patriarcale et ma mère était plutôt
discrète et mais mais son sa
satisfaction son sourire et sa joie
quand elle quand elle nous voyait manger
était tout à fait vous avez un petit
truc là sur que vous tenez de votre de
votre maman ou de votre papa pardon
est-ce que vous tenez de votre maman ou
de V non je je je crois que les les gens
qu' ont connu mon père quand il me
voit ils savent bien d'où je
viens on sait aussi euh vous nous disiez
que vous cultiviez du coup ces légumes
est-ce que vous on vous retrouvait aussi
derrière les fourneaux de temps en temps
est-ce que vous aimez cuisiner oui oui
moi je
oui oui tout de suite je me suis
intéressé
puis quand j'ai commencé à
habiter en dehors de mes parents quand
j'ai pris mon émancipation j'ai habité
avec des camarades on on était en
communauté dans une on avait loué un un
P tout ça et on s'intéressait beaucoup à
la à la à la cuisine enfin et au magasin
bio on achetait que des des légumes on
achetait du du des des graines on
achetait du des des tout un tas de de de
produits vous étiez très avantgardistes
alorsur mais on n'était pas du tout
avant-gardiste moi mes parents en
1946 à la fin de la guerre ils étaient
ils étaient adhérents à La Vie Claire
qu'est-ce qui un circuit qui s qui s'est
monté à cette époque
là l'écologie et le fait de d'essayer de
se nourrir bien les les les gens ils
avaient c'est pas nouveau et les gens
ils avaient déjà compris qu'on allait
aller dans un monde industriel et qu'il
fallait faire gaffe est-ce que ce goût
des bons légumes du de l'authentique
légume que vous aviez enfant est-ce que
vous le retrouvez aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous allez justement dans des enseignes
un peu spécialisé bio pour pouvoir
retrouver ce goûtl et et est-ce qu'il
existe toujours alors
j'ai j'ai la chance d'avoir une maison
secondaire dans le sud de la France et
autour de autour de chez moi il y a je
suis entouré par un
maricher et ce marécher donc
jeidment je mange de ces produits lui il
est pas bio du tout non
enfin il s met vaguement mais bon non B
lui il convainc c'est difficile
mais mais mais il fait des trucs
formidables mais mais je vois bien que
même quand c'est pas bio la qualité d'un
d'un d'un légume est formidable quand
vous mangez quelque chose qui a été
cueilli le matin h quand c'est frais
voilà transporter des légumes
transporter des fruits le transport est
quelque chose qui altère totalement la
la qualité de gustative bah ça les abîme
ou alors il faut les transporter quand
ils sont pas m il faut des quantités
tout ça bon alors là mais si je vous
écoute vous êtes plus local que bio si
vous préférez aller à côté de chez vous
acheter un produit qui va pas être
transporté même s'il a des des
pesticides j'évite quand même j'essaie
de oui les pesticides c'est
évidemment évidemment que c'est très
nocif pour le pour l'organisme ça
détruit beaucoup de choses à l'intérieur
de de notre façon de de s'adapter ça ça
finit par détruire des choses très
importantes comme notre système
immunitaire tout ça donc doncut
évidemment y faire attention mais au
niveau gustatif
vraiment la la la fraîcheur et qu'
manger quelque chose de local ça c'est
évidemment c'est imbattable c'est
imbattable on va revenir sur cette
blanquette et Jean-Pierre vous allez
nous dire tris trois secrets de de chef
pour cuisiner la blanquette parce que on
a déjà beaucoup parlé de la blanquette
dans alors je ne sais pas quel était le
secret de la maman de Jean-Pierre
daroussa mais les chefs ont des petits
secrets pour finir la la recette au
moment où on doit faire la petite crème
qui qui finit la blanquette alors pour
ch ligac pas de bonnes blanquett sans ce
rou he délicatement préparé avec du
beurre de la farine avec le bouillon
parfumé de la viande auquel il ajoute de
la crème fraîche mais pour ligac jamais
d'œuf c'est un sacrilège en revanche
l'œuf c'est le secret de Jean-François
Piège qui lui fouette le jaune d'œuf
dans le restant de crème avant de verser
une louche de sauce très chaude histoire
de détendre la crème et de verser cette
petite composition sur la blanquette et
puis enfin il y a Philippe et chebes lui
pas d'œuf met de la crème et mais cette
crème il va la F fouitter comme pour la
rendre un peu aérienne légère onctueuse
il va y ajouter un peu de citron pour la
la prendre pour laattendre et il va
ajouter ça à sa blanquette donc voilà
trois petits secrets de chef pour
réussir une blanquette et et vous est-ce
que vous votre maman vous a j'ai j'ai
jamais vu ma mère mettre un uf dans une
blanquette je ne pense pas dans est Plô
elle est plutôt sur la par contre le
citron par contre le citron je pense que
oui qui relève qui donne un petit point
d'acidité à cette blanquette elle vous a
transmis sa sa recette est-ce que vous
vous la vous la faites la blanquette à
la maison non
non
non non c'était sa recette et je pense
qu'elle est
elle transmettait pas c'était elle avait
ses prérogatives sur mais vous en mangez
toujours volontiers de la blanquette ou
ça fait un peu partie d'une petite
Madeleine qui qui reste un souvenir euh
ça fait partie d'une petite Madeleine
qui reste un souvenir auquel je voilà
donc voilà je ça m'arrive si ça m'arrive
de d'en manger dans dans des restaurant
tout ça mais c'est pas un plat qu'on
qu'on prépare à la maison on n' pas
compris si vous étiez un artiste
derrière les fourneaux vousêes derrière
l'écran derrière la caméra mais derrière
les four vous êtes bon vous êtes moyen
vous faites ça par devoir par obligation
ou non je j'aime être dans dans la
recherche des saveurs de faire de de de
des mélanges tout ça enfin j'aime bien
tester des choses j'aime élaborer des
plats
euh mais il se trouve que je je je je
vis en couple avec une femme qui c'est
aussi fait très très bien la la cuisine
aussi donc on on se partage on est un
peu on est tous les deux au fourneau
ensemble par c'est pas toujours
simplementa ça je je fais le
comis VO chacun a son rôle voilà je fais
je fais le comis volontier et et puis de
temps ens second une fois alors que vous
ne jouez que des premiers rôles ou pas
forcément mais je trouve ça très
intéressant aussi d'être d'être second
ça ne m'a jamais je me suis jamais senti
minoré parce que j'étais second
euh non
c'est non oui j'ai accepé ça mais mais
ça m'arrive aussi que ce soit moi qui
qui qui dirige si c'est moi qui a
l'initiative mais je reconnais qu'elle a
plus souvent l'initiative que moi voilà
vous nous parliez de d'une maison dans
dans le sud c'est plutôt de la cuisine
méditerranéenne c'est quels sont les
plats que vous cuisinez régulièrement
peut-être chez vous oui alors c'est vrai
que les gens sont content de devenenir
alors par exemple quand là c'est moi qui
le fais la soupe au pistou ah oui la
soupe au pistou c'est c'est moi qui l'a
fait c'est bon c'est typique de ouais et
quand au mortier le pistou oui oui le
mortier au pistou je suis un spécialiste
du mortier pour les aolis non non mais
c'est c'est c'est vrai je je suis
spécialiste du du mais il faut un bon
mortier faut un bon mortier oui oui
c'est alors la Yoli comment vous le
faites on écrase beaucoup d'ail puis on
monte ça à l'huile c'est ça oui
absolument ouais oui oui oui je c'est
c'est c'est tout simple c'est une
mayonnaise donne ce petit côté
mayonnaise aussi il faut vraiment un bon
coup de
à la à la place de à la place de la
moutarde vous vous vous faites votre
pâte de votre pâte d'ail et puis vous
montez vous montez ça mais une
mayonnaise moi je aussi je suis aussi
ESP alors ça la mayonnaise on me demande
aussi toujours de la faire la mayonnaise
le roi de la mayonnaise c'est moi qui
fait la mayonnaise
et puis vous avez un plat préféré dont
vous ne nous avez pas parlé mais qu'on a
trouvé nous c'est la tomate FARC oui je
je sais justement mais c'est aussi lié à
ma mère
elle elle les faisait très très bien ça
était délicieux ces tomates farcis et je
sais que quand elle voulait me faire
plaisir j'avais droit à des tomates
farcis il y avait deux truc c'était les
côtelettes de porc et les tomates FARC
ça je savais que c'était pour moi pour
vous faire plaisir CTA c'était ça
m'était destiné c'était pour vous donc
ça ce sont des des souvenirs des
souvenirs d'enfance et puis pour
accompagner cette blanquette vous nous
avez demandé un verre de vin de bando
donc nous avons choisi ce ce rosé donc
de de Provence c'est une naocé Bandole
contrôlée un millisim 2022 le sépage
qu'on retrouve là-bas c'est la mour Vred
le mour Vred le M le mot verdre c'est
difficile à dire euh et puis alors c'est
un rosé donc c'est un il y a beaucoup de
fraîcheur il y a beaucoup de fruités il
y a des notes d'agrume vous nous aviez
demandé un Bandle rouge et ou sinon rosé
c'est vrai que j'étais un petit peu
étonné par la couleur le rosé c'est
plutôt plutôt l'été mais on en trouve
maintenant toute l'année oui je je je je
suis tout à fait pour euh pour
promouvoir et réhabiliter le le rosé qu'
un vin qui va vraiment avec sur un repas
ça va avec tout de de depuis l'entré
jusqu'à jusqu'au dessert le rosé ça va
très bien alors évidemment il faut qu'il
il soit de très bonne qualité on a des
rosé qu'on a
justement on a fait un peu pisser la
vigne pour pouvoir faire de la
consommation rapide et et en quantité
l'été pour faire boire du rosé tout ça
mais il y a des gens qui travaillent
bien et qui qui font des rosés vraiment
vraiment délicieux et le rosé ça peut
être un vin merveilleux évidemment
j'aime beaucoup les rouges aussi et les
blancs c'est c'est des vins et mais il
se trouve qu'en bando les blancs sont
merveilleux les rouges sont merveilleux
et les rosés sont merveilleux auss tout
les couleurs et et voilà et c'est et
Bandol c'est une région que vous
affectionnez particulièrement parce que
vous y passez aussi quelques vacances
parce que c'est bah parce que justement
cette cette maison secondaire dont je
dont je parlais tout à l'heure all est
dans les vignes entouré d'un un maréché
mais les viges sont là aussi pas très
loin du côté les viges de B de Bandol
oui mais Brigitte peut-être ce qui
galvonne galv par le rosé c'est que les
Français le boivent quand il fait très
chaud ils veulent du vin frais et du
coup sous la fraîcheur on cache
n'importe quel vin effectivement c'est
peut-être pas une bonne idée de le boire
l'hiver comme on le fait aujourd'hui oui
parce qu'il il pas il est pas glacé là
vous pas l'air convaincu non mais on
peut on peut trouver aujourd'hui très
bon rosé mais même s'il est frais un
mauvais rosé je pense qu'on peut trouver
qu'il est qu'il est mauvais mais ça
c'est un goût personnel mais buvons du
rosé enfin buvons avec modération mais
l'hiver pourquoi pas oui toujours avec
modération oui enfin moi je j'ai pas de
problème pour boire un quand il est bon
si c'est un bon rosé c'est bon quoi
voilà alors on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollable c'est le
quiz alors Jean-Pierre d'oussa on vient
de l'entendre he les tomates farcies
sont donc un de vos plats préférés
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations concernant cette fameuse
tomate sont vraies ou fausses la tomate
est un légume fruit originaire du
Mexique vrai ou faux je crois que c'est
vrai oui vrai du mot tomati en langue
asteèque alors certains disent que c'est
le Pérou mais visiblement c'est le cœur
le berceau de la tomate c'est le Mexique
ce sont les 100 culottes marseillais qui
juste après la révolution en 1790 font
découvrir la tomate aux
Parisiens c'est probable oui parce
qu'elle arrive elle arrive dans les
bagages de Colom par l'Espagne et
l'Italie donc à Marseille d'abord en
France on pense que la tomate c'est
c'est pas une c'est une plante et c'est
un fruit de décoration et pas un légume
et c'est les Marseillais qui vont faire
goûter la tomate au parisiens en France
la première recette de tomate FARC à
base de chair à sauciss est publiée en
1803 par grimaau de la
Reinière en 1803 bah pourquoi pas
puisque c'était les 100 culottes qui
nont amené on est cohérent là-dessus on
est cohérent mais oui c'est vrai votre
logique est imparable c'est vrai c'est
le chef dromois que vous devez connaître
André pic qui va faire entrer la tomate
Farcy dans ce qu'on appelle la
gastronomie
française alors
euh je crois que oui alors non c'est
Paul Bocuse qui en 1976 et bien fait une
recette gastronomique de la tomate FARC
la tomate Farcy entre dans le pantéon de
la cuisine française quand même trois
bonnes réponses sur quatre c'est pas mal
deuxème quiz vous l'acteur du film culte
le cœur des hommes sauriez-vous nous
dire quel cœur en cuisine est désigné
par un espèce de bulbe qui unit les
branches
a le cœur de l'ITU B le cœur
d'artichaud c le cœur de célerie d le
cœur de palmier un bulbe qui unit les
branches bah
euh alors le le premier vous avez dit
c'est alors c'est le cœur de l'éu bah
oui c'est le cœur de l'éu non c'est pas
le cœur de l'éu c'est le cœur de
cellerlerie le bulbe ah le célerie
d'accord le bulbe oui bien sûr c'est
bien sûr la cellerlerie c'est bulbe
voilà j'avais oublié le mot bulbe
c'était le piège c'était le piège alors
c'est souvent autour de la table vous
devez le savoir Jean-Pierre Daroussin
que ce raconte les meilleures histoires
que ce nous parfois des deals politiques
que se fait en tout cas la petite et la
grande Histoire et c'est la breève de
comptoir alors Jean-Pierre Daroussin on
vous a demandé de réfléchir
éventuellement une anecdote autour d'un
repas pourquoi pas en politique mais
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs de de
déjeuner de dîner avec des des hommes ou
des femmes politique ça m'est arrivé
quelquefois oui mais euh mais justement
pour si on on on retourne à Bandol ça ça
je jouais art au Théâtre Antoine avec
Charles Berling et Alain fromager pièce
de Yasmine arza qu'on a joué pas mal ça
a fait un gros succès et euh
Emmanuel Macron et et sa femme Brigit
sont venus voir le spectacle et après le
spectacle dans le
dans le foyer du théâtre une table a été
rapidement dressée des bouteilles ont
été sorties et on a mangé ensemble après
le spectacle comme ça ils on parler du
spectacle et la conversation est venue
justement sur bando parce que
il dire bah avec Brigitte on va souvent
en vacances à bando tout çach et là et
Macron me dit mais le vin mais le vin de
Bandole maintenant c'est mieux mais
avant c'était pas terrible là je suis
dit là attendez là monsieur le Président
vous êtes un petit peu jeunau sur la
question parce que franchement ça ça
fait quand même de ça fait quelques
années c'est une des régions où où où
les les viticulteurs sont en grande
majorité bio et en biodynamie depuis
très longtemps et ceux qui n'étaient pas
l'étit sans savoir comme comme Monsieur
Jourdain faisait de la prose sans sans
sans sans savoir moi je connais des des
viticulteurs de bandool qui en sont
alors 64 ou 6 5è vénification tellement
ils ont depuis longtemps ils ont
toujours ils ont jamais mis un intran
jamais mis un pesticide jamais quoi que
ce soit dans le dans dans leur vigne ils
ont toujours été très très
précautionneux de de la façon a moins
d'humidité aussi donc moins de
développement de de peut-être les
conditions sont bonnes enfin en tous les
cas ils en profitent et ils en font
profiter les autres aussi de ce travail
là donc voilà mon mon anecdote avec avec
de la politique autour d'une le
président
bâché depuis le bois du
Bandol alors je le disais Jean-Pierre
Daroussin vous êtes un des acteurs
fétige de Robert guediguian on se doute
qu'il vous a emmené manger une bouill
àaisse dans son fief alors quel est le
secret de cet emblème de la cuisine
marseillaise c'est le dessous des
plats alors brgit évidemment impossible
d'évoquer Marseille sans parler de la
bouill àabis c'est un totem de la
cuisine CN trop souvent copié parfois
massacré alors à quoi ressemble
l'authentique bouillabaisse et bien pour
cela Clément perouau notre reporter
s'est rendu dans le port des Goudes pour
assister à sa préparation et bien sûr la
dégusté
reportage les Goudes un petit port
marseillais aux aires de bout du
monde c'est ici qu'est installé Benjamin
Mathieu ça va ti chef cuisinier
passionné par le plat le plus
emblématique de de la cité faosséenne
alors qu'est-ce que tu as pêché de beau
ce matin la bouille baisse ce matin pas
chose tu des petites trascass une
vieille des ça ou vieille ouais des ça
ça sort de l'eau là ouais oua ça sort de
l'eau c'estore put ils sont beau je vais
te prendre les rascasses la vieille
quelques SAR hein allez a pas de
problème ouais mais ça ça donne du goût
he ah je sais très très bien la faire
aussi je suis pas cuisigné mais je la
fais très très bien c'est vrai j'ai
jamais goûté ta bouill j'en ai fait pour
50 60 personnes des belles belles
bouillab avec Tito pêcheur au gû depuis
des décennies le chef a trouvé les
poissons de roche indispensa à sa
bouille à baisse il va pouvoir les
ajouter au bouillon qui chauffe déjà
depuis plusieurs heures du safrin
quelques épices quelques aromates et
après voilà beaucoup de poisson pour la
quantité d'eau qu'on met ça nous assure
d'avoir un très bon goût de poisson
d'orange d'accord le nou c'est du
Marseillais c'est du provençal c'est
très simple bouille abaisse quand ça
boue
tuabaisse issue du bouillon filtré la
soupe est la première étape de la
bouille à baisse qui traditionnellement
se sert en deux temps dans sa deuxième
cuisine Benjamin Mathieu va s'attaquer à
la seconde partie plusieurs espèces de
poissons sont pochés dans la soupe avec
des pommes de terre voilà le rouge et
Grondin la vive petit chapon c'est à peu
près 3 4 minutes par poisson tout le
goût des poissons de roche va
s'infiltrer dans la chair il va pénétrer
dans la chair des poissons de la bouill
àaisse d'accord ça va leur donner une
texture une couleur et un goût vraiment
particulier une fois le poisson cuit ne
reste plus qu'à préparer les
filets dans le restaurant du grand bar
des Goudes les clients dégustent leur
bouill à baisse face à la mer plat
historiquement populaire elle est
devenue un repas de luxe proposé sur
commande à 55 € par personne à cette
table ses clients belges sont des
inconditionnels de poisson épicé et avec
une certaine structure qui est du le
poisson qui doit être mixé hyper fa
c'est c'est c'est très bon c'est du bon
la mer dans mon
assiette la Méditerranée dans l'assiette
les vrais savent la bouill à baisse à le
goût de
Marseille Jean-Pierre d'ousembou qui
avait beaucoup tourné à Marseille ça
faisait parti un peu des des moments de
pause des des tournages le la bouille à
baisse l'événement bouill à baisse dans
le port de Marseille ou dans le port des
Goudes de l'Estac même la bouill à baiss
c'est quand même assez long et et
compliqué à préparer hein c'est pas un
plat qui il faut et mais c'est vrai qu'
à Marseille on connaît il y en a un peu
dans dans différents quartiers ou dans
différentes calanque il y a des pêcheurs
donc on le matin pouvoir récupérer
encore une
fois des produits frais S et quand et
est préparé pour faire une bouille à
baisse ou un aioli parce que vraiment
moi j'aime beaucoup aussi l'oli chose
comme ça mais bon enfin dans ces
spécialités méditerranéennes euh oui oui
les poissons la façon dont ça mais ce
qui la la la bouill àaisse c'est le
safran aussi le safran qui relève en
fait le le goût de le safran c'est quand
même une une fauter le safran c'est
c'est vraiment intéressant ça Fran à
travailler vraiment vraiment et vous en
avez dégusté effectivement avec Robert
gedigan ça vous arrive de stopper le
tournage pour aller stopper le tournage
ngagerons pas si vous dites ça
Robert ça va pas du toutbr le tournage
allez avec une bonne Bou non ça arrive
oui c'est c'est arrivé qu' qu' qu'on
aille dans des restaurants dans les
restaurants marseillais qui ont la
spécialité dont on on connaî dont on
sait on connaît les adresses on sait où
il y a quelques endroits où la la BA est
très bonne oui et et vous vous l'aimez
particulièrement vous êtes assez fan de
poissons aussi oui oui oui oui les
poissons mais mais moi j'aime bien les
poissons aussi cuits par exemple en
croûte de
sel je trouve que oui à
l'étouffé un poisson frais oui un
poisson les poissons de toutes sortes
c'est c'est toujours très bon mais
encore une fois quand on a la chance ou
alors même soi-même ça m déjà arrivé
aussi moi de d'être sur un bateau de de
laisser
une ça c'est un peu plus dans le Nord
c'est pas trop dans en Méditerranée mais
de laisser une ligne et de prendre des
macros comme ça et de les mettre
directement dans la poêle sur le bateau
comme il se balade en B en plus on
attrape pas Malou attrape pas mal et
c'est et là le le le le ce qu'on mange
est est merveilleux c'est ça n'a pas
rien à voir avec le goût qu'on même si
parfois il y a des très bons
poissonniers à Paris il y a des très
bons poissonniers évidemment il y a eu
un peu de transport le temps que ça nous
AR oui mais bon il y a quand même il y
en a quand même franchement il on trouve
des des des des des poissonneries où
vraiment on peut je sais que le le le
poisson a été pêché très tôt le matin
ils ont fait le trajet dans des dans des
camions réfrigérés et ils arrivent mais
c'est vrai que de la mer à la poêle il y
a pas plus court comme comme circuit oui
ça c'est alors 55 € vous trouvez que
c'est cher ou vous trouvez que ça le
mérite parce que vous l'avez dit
vous-même c'est long à préparer il a y a
des PO pas travail il y a c'est pas des
poissons nobles pour autant mais c'est
des poissons durs il faut poissons de
roche oui mais justement on en prend on
en pêche pas des grosses quantités euh
c'est vraiment c'est c'est une pêche
très artisanale faut on a son petit
pointu le matin on part on part à l'aube
et c'est pas et on ramène quelques
poissons c'est c'est ils ont des des
vies assez difficiles ces pêcheurs là
donc je pense que déjà que le que le
pêcheur soit rémunéré
à à son prix normal et puis en ce moment
bah malgré tout on on n pas encore passé
au pointu électrique il faut payer le le
gasoil je je je pense que tout ça se
répercute sur le prix de la boutivement
sur le prix de la bouille à baisse et et
du poisson 19 je sa pas vousz une char
qui éé établ par les restaurateurs
marseillais pour définir laette
officielle de la Bouab vous disiez la
vraie l'authentique bouillabe parce que
il y a eu quand même pas mal de de
copies pensez que ça mériterait
peut-être une AOP une AOC je ne sais pas
pour consacrer cette cette recette
authentique de la bouillae c'est très
difficile cette notion d'AOP d'AOC parce
que soit ça
fige et donc ça empêche l'invention et
la re
cherche regardez il y a des vins le
nombre de vignerons on sait bien à
l'heure actuelle qui sont qui sont des
des
vignerons qui tentent des aventures qui
tentent des façons de faire du vin
autrement et qui ne correspondent pas
aux ches qui ont été défin dans la
région par exemple voilà comme ça et qui
donc sont obligés de sortir de
l'appellation mais il y a marqué 20 de
France voilà et des fois on tombe sur
des vins absolument merveilleux et ils
non'ont pas ils ne bénéficient pas de
l'appellation et c'est plus difficile à
vendre quand on n pas effectivement
l'appellationà moi je trouve que un si
après après voilà si on arrive à
échapper de toute façon de façon
générale si on arrive à échapper pour un
produit quel qu'il soit au marketing et
si on s'en rend compte par soi-même
c'est toujours mieux c'est-à-dire que si
on va dans un restaurant et qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui vous propose une bouill à
baisse qui n'est pas authentique mais
vous la trouvez très bonne et ben ça
sera une bonne bouille à baisse et puis
sur les labels c'est aussi compliqué de
mettre une AOP et une AOC sur une
recette qui qui est constitutif de plein
de produits différents donc c'est plus
compliqué que sur un monooduit où on
peut donner l'origine et cetera parce
que quel est l'intérêt du type du mais
par contre qu'une charte existe en
disant voilà quelle est la recette de la
vrai l'authentique avec un VO vra et
puis après on peut s'en éloigner ça
bénéficie à qui de faire ça bah si parce
que je suis sûr que vous avez mangé vous
êtes fait arnaquer à Marseille vous avez
mangé une mauvaise bouill à ba déjà ouis
je quand je je ne vais pas dans un dans
un
restaurantourist à Marseille je connais
quand même oui mais y a il y a des
touristes anglais qui sont à voir parce
qu'ils connaissent pas ils ont pas
tourné g donc il sonont à voir alors
évidemment on parle de Robert gedigan on
parle de Marseille dont il est
originaire son dernier film et la fête
continue dans lequel vous jouez et bien
tourner à Marseille où en 2018 les
immeubles on s'en souvient de la rue
d'au se sont effondrés on va regarder la
bande annonce
ensemble il faut affirmer sans cesse que
rien n'est fini que tout
commence pour gagner il faut trois
choses
le programme et le programme moi je
pense que justement ce qu'il faudrait
c'est nouvelle tête Nau
cerau je voulais vous présenter Alice on
va se marier tout est déjà programmé on
aura enfant bienvenue chez nous cour'il
plat
merille c'est ma
filleerci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
prenez des routi tout la Méditerranée
comme
vous si tu savais mais quoi j'ai fait
l'amour et tu trouves ça drôle je sais
pas ça t'a plu bah oui ça m'a
plu avec la situation tragique des
logements des écoles le fruit et mur et
ce serait atroce de perdre parce qu'on
est pas arrivé à se mettre d'accord sur
la tête de liste ça j'aimerais tellement
qu'une seule fois tu soisé ben on y est
pas alors Marseille ça vous plaît tous
les gens il sont de hoch ici pas de
bourgeois pas de e il y a que des
BR je sais pas pourquoi je su SP comme
ça quand on a envie de changer le monde
comme toi on a du
boul C qu' attendent
[Musique]
tous alors Jeanpierre d'ousin AR joue le
personnage de Rosa qui ressemble
étrangement à Michel rubira qui s fait
élire à Marseille c'est c'est le pitch
qui vous a plu le scénario ou vous dites
toujours oui à Robert guedigan je dis
toujours oui à roberton alors le parce
que vous n'êtes jamais
déçu alors il se trouve que je suis
jamais déçu mais c'est pas ça ça rentre
pas en ligne de compte ce qui ce qui
rentre en ligne de compte c'est la
fabrication c'est le fait d'être à la
tâche dans notre travail qui est de
faire du cinéma ensemble parce que voilà
c'est comme ça que ça s c'est comme ça
que ça s'est combiné la vie c'est comme
ça que ça s'est agancé on a c'est une
histoire d'amitié c'est une histoire
d'amitié et donc on on fabrique du
cinéma ensemble chacun a son poste et
chacun alors avec des fois des des des
des ça sentremelle un petit peu mais
mais disons que j'ai pas de raison j'ai
aucune raison de de refuser parce que je
sais qu'après on va travailler on va
même s'il y a des choses qui peuvent
être des fois qu'on peut améliorer sur
un sur un scénario mais ça va être des
broutis et donc globalement l'écriture
est est est ça va il commence à savoir
le faire quand même donc mais il y a
souvent un message derrière les films de
Robert gedigan il y a aussi beaucoup
d'authenticité c'est c'est ça que vous
recherchez c'est c'est c'est engagé
pratiquement à à sa manière oui alors
c'est engagé c'est-à-dire que évidemment
quand on fait du cinéma on on essaie de
de de de de projeter pu c'est le cas
c'est le cinéma de projeter une vision
du monde de projeter une oui une morale
une éthique on parle beaucoup de morale
et d'éthique en ce moment pour essayer
de se rattraper aux branches sur des sur
sur des valeurs donc on a des valeurs
donner du sens à sa vie donner de tout
truc moi ça c'est toujours mais de
toutes les époques que les les gens sont
concernés par ça quand on écrit des
romans quand on quand on écrit enfin
quand on propose quelque chose aux
autres on a forcément la la la la
conscience d'essayer de proposer quelque
chose qui qui va qui va les les qui va
leur rapporter quelque chose les les les
les gens qui sont dans la salle sont des
client c'est c'est comme dans les
restaurants on essaie de on si vous
proposez un produit que tout le monde
connaît alors évidemment les gens vont y
aller en masse ça si vous voulez un
hamburger avec des fr là voilà voilà
voilà là les gens vont y aller en masse
parce qu'ils connaissent on sait ce que
c'est on va pas être déçu on sait que
c'est voilà pas pas on ce que c'est on
est pas forcment dé non parce que quand
même malgré tout il y a
Robert oui mais c'est quelqu'un qui qui
évolue aussi avec le temps donc son son
il traduit sa pensée du moment de
l'instant par rapport à ce qu'il vit
avec dans son contexte familial par
rapport à à à ce qui vit dans dans le
contexte de de de social a dans lequel
il est dans là où il habite dans ce qui
se passe tout ça il reçoit des des
émotions il essaie de les traduire au
cinéma et en et et et en parler voilà
c'est c'est c'est tout le message non
pourquoi il y aurait un message il y a
pas de message il y a zéro message dans
les films de Rober gedigan ça serait
quoi le messageès vision de la vie c'est
une vision de la vie non mais c'est il y
a zéro message vraiment il y a il y a
absolument zéro message il y a
simplement montrer la vie tel qu'on
voilà les choses telles qu'on pense que
c'est que c'est et que ça devrait être
pour nous mais c'est toujours une simple
qui est montré c'est une vie très
authentique c'est dire que quand oui
mais pourquoi voulez-vous parler de de
de gens que vous connaissez pas nous on
parle de nous
h ça ça peut arriver aussi évidemment de
d'écrire des des des contes et Légend
pourquoi pas je sa mais c'est pas c'est
pas son propos Robert lui voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui qui traduit de ce qu'il
ressent et ce qui se passe autour de lui
donc il y a pas il y a pas forcément de
message il a y a zéro message ce serait
ça serait quoi le message ça serait
qu'il faut être qu'il faut être
solidaire qu'il faut essayer de trouver
du lien les uns entre les autres j'en ai
vu un
alors allez-y ben faire des pâtes aux
anchois à l'ail et au noix parce que moi
je suis je suis l'estomat de cette cette
édition ça ça m'a mis lot à la bouche
quand j'ai vu le film et vous n'êtes pas
dans la scène où on goûte ces pâtes vous
les avez quand même goûté oui oui je je
connais la la la la recette familiale la
la la la la recette ça c'est c'est
effectivement une
recette c'est du côté de la famille
d'Arian ça euh c'est italien c'est
arménien
c'est je crois que c'est plutôt
napolitain oui donc c'est du côté
d'Arian ou en tous les cas c'est une
bonne promo pour cette recette et moi je
suis sorti du film en disant tiens je
vais aller cuisiner des non non c'est
très bon et c'est c'est c'est très très
bon mais dans les films de Robert il y a
T quasiment toujours une recette il y a
souvent une chanson il faut qu'il fasse
un livre populaire il y a souvent une
chanson populaire et il y a souvent une
recette aussi on a déjà fait les pates
au Clevis on a déjà fait justement le la
la Yoli enfin il y a toujours parce que
justement parce que le repas c'est
quelque chose où les gens se retrouvent
c'est là où il y a du lien populaire
c'est c'est voilà donc il y a pas de
message à à à à parler de ce que les de
de de ce que les gens vivent tout
simplement quoi il y a aucun message là
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a des des
des des immeubles qui s'écroule dans une
rue à cause de la misère de la précarité
et et et de quelquesuns qui sont
et de quelques qui sont qui cherchent à
faire du profit facilement avec les gens
qui sont dans dans la misère
bon on se retrouve dans une situation ça
c'est des des choses qu'on vit ça c'est
arrivé encore d'autres fois c'est
rearrivé à Marseille encore c'est arrivé
dans d'autres villes Bordeaux il y a pas
aussi long temps enfin bon il y AAS
d'endroits où ça arrive voilà on parle
d'une réalité qui pas c'est il y a pas
de message on a bien enfin je veux dire
il y a aucun message à dire tiens voilà
il y a des gens qui ont vécu des drames
quoi et on en parle au cinéma on va pas
façonim ou profitent de la situation
quand Mme mais c'est pas stabile bossé
c'est juste comme ça voilà c'est c'est
c'est voilà on on peut faire de on peut
s'engager quand évidemment quand on
montre des exemples si à l'heure
actuelle on fait par exemple une un
personnage féminin qui est qui euh qui
qui prend le pouvoir quelque part qui
qui se qui qui s'affranchit de du
patriarcat sans même le savoir parce que
alors que c'est pas une militante
féministe si on si on si on si on écrit
ça par exemple voilà peut-être que
derrière il peut y avoir un message
parce que évidemment on on défend
certaines valeurs mais défendre des
valeurs
c'est mais vous vous avez l'impression
d'être un artiste engagé en faisant ces
films engagé franchement honnêtement
j'arrive pas trop à savoir engager ça
voudrait dire que je que je je que je
prends alors évidemment j'ai des
positions j'ai des des pensées je lis
des choses j'essaie j'essaie oui mais
c'est des donc j'essaie de les
communiquer c'est même ce que je je suis
en train de en train de faire en ce
moment quand je parle de la d'être
flexitarien par exemple puisque c'est un
peu ça finalement quand je quand je
parle de de de de manger des choses en
dans de proximité euh à quel point c'est
important de de se constituer des
défenses immunitaires à travers le fait
de vraiment manger les bons les les les
bons oligoéléments les bons minéraux les
Bones les bon les bonnes vitamines les
tout ce qui va pouvoir vous aider à bien
digérer les aliments et vous faire une
bonne santé qui va vous permettre de
résister aux aux épidémies qui aux
maladie sociale comme on dit maintenant
mais que ça soit les les les les les
dépressions ou les cancers ou que ça
soit les les tout ces toutes ces tout
ces ces phénomènes de société qui sont
essentiellement du ha stress que les que
les individus vive évidemment moi quand
je vous dis que jusqu'à 15 ans j'ai vécu
tranquillement sans me préoccuper de ce
que j'allais faire dans mon avenir parce
qu'à cette époque là on s'en préoccupait
pas c'était pas on avait pas cette
conscience là alors que maintenant vous
vous interrogez un gamin de 13 ans ou 14
ans dans une dans dans dans une cours
d'école ils sont tous angoissés de ce
qu'ils vont faire parce qu'on leur met
de la pression on leur dit faut devenir
quelque chose faut devenir quelqu'un il
faut gagner de l'argent ou angoisser par
le monde et la tournure que pr par le
monde aussi aussi tout ce qui tout ce
qui se passe autour parce que effectiv
on prend pas soin de la la planète parce
qu'on prend pas soin de la façon dont on
mange on prend pas soin de beaucoup de
choses ils le sentent bien ça les les
les enfants qu'on prend pas soin des on
prend pas soin parce qu'on pourquoi
parce qu'on se préoccupe que du
rendement économique donc si on se
préoccupe que du rendement économique
évidemment on on court à la catastrophe
au niveau sanitaire au niveau éducatif
au niveau tout ça on court à à la
catastrophe donc oui les les forcément
on crée du stress on crée il faut faire
sa place on n pas le temps là on dit on
parle de ce que qu- pas dans l'assiette
là on parle du temps mais vous rendez
compte au nombre de gens qui qui mangent
que des sandwichs le midi alors
justement encore faut-il pouvoir manger
un sandwich parce que aujourd'hui en
France beaucoup de personnes ne mangent
pas à leur fin et la situation s'aggrave
on en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat l'inflation alimentaire déclenchée
par la guerre en Ukraine plonge un
nombre important de français dans une
précarité conséquence de plus en plus de
personnes pousse la porte des Restos du
cœur mais cette année l'association va
être obligée de refuser du monde 1300000
personnes seront néanmoins accueillis
d'autres bénéficieront des collectes des
Banques Alimentaires reportage hlè
Bonduel et Clément Perou bonjour madame
c'est une collecte pour la Banque
Alimentaire voilà merci Madame 3 jours
de collecte dans les grandes
surfaces madame merci beaucoup
courage viment bien avoir donné c'est
formidable et ici déjà une quarantaine
de caisses remplies en une matinée les
gens de ils ont vraiment besoin et nous
on a tout ce qu'il faut mais on pour moi
c'est très important une collecte
d'autant plus nécessaire cette année
pour les banques alimentaires les
besoins ont augmenté de près de 10 % au
3è trimestre alors la Fédération a dû
limiter ses dons aux associations c'est
un peu le choix cornélien qui qui est
devant nous c'est d'accueillir plus de
personnes mais continuer à apporter une
aide alimentaire de qualité donc oui sur
certains produits il nous arrive de
d'être obligé de restreindre la quantité
qu'on va distribuer et puis surtout on a
des stocks qui sont quasiment à zéro sur
des certains produits et la collecte
aujourd'hui va nous permettre de
remonter les stocks de ces produits
c'est vrai sur les les plats cuisinés ça
va être vrai sur les conserves de fruits
ou de légumes qu'on demande
spécifiquement d'ailleurs où les pâtes
et le riz qui sont des produits de
première nécessité mais qui aujourd'hui
coût cher inflation crise du pouvoir
d'achat 7 millions de personnes
dépendent aujourd'hui de l'aide
alimentaire comme ici au resto du cœur
de
Grenoble une
banan je peux vous donner une banane un
peu plus noire gratuite vraiment c'est
compliqué c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
de venir ici et de reçu laide qui donne
les gens reste de cure et c'est vraiment
grâce à elle que je peux manger que j'ai
peux voilà mais les association ne sont
pas épargné non plus par la crise il y a
3 mois les restos du cœur L appel au don
il leur manquait 35 millions d'euros
pour la première fois les restos sont
obligés de refuser des bénéficiaires
dans ce centre ce sont 60 familles qui
n'ont pas pu être accepté c'est vraiment
un crveœur pour les bénévoles déjà de
devoir dire non parce que notre mission
c'est pas de dire non mission c'est de
dire oui maximum de personnes au niveau
national c'est près de 10 % des
personnes accueillies l'an dernier par
les restos du cœur qui ne pourront plus
l'être cette année Jean-Pierre Daroussin
les restes du cœur obligés de refuser du
monde 7 millions de personnes qui
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire ça vous
révolte bah 7 millions ça commence à
faire beaucoup quand
même je pense qu'effectivement c'est
difficile d'éradiquer la misère la
misère elle n'est pas elle n'est pas que
produite par le que par l'organisation
de la société est c'est aussi structurel
parfois un niveau individuel
mais c'est utopique de supprimer la
misère mais par contre c'est pas
utopique de l'aider et
de et de combler cette injustice au
maximum que que faire se peut donc qu'il
ait des de pouvoir soutenir évidemment
les bénévoles puisqueil y a quand même
des gens qui s'engagent des gens qui
donnent de leur temps des gens qui
travaillent beaucoup pour
pour que ce soit les restau du cœur les
banqu alimentaire et pas l'état
finalement
qui qui qui vient qui vient en aide à à
ces personnes qui peuvent pas qui
peuvent pas manger à leur fin l'état
donne une petite part hein mais est-ce
que est-ce que c'est normal de
sou la part de l'État n'est pas
suffisante donc l'État doit augmenter ce
qu'elle donne pour ces associations on
dirait c'est une faillite de l'État on
dirait queeffectivement l'État ne bah
oui l'État doit prendre en compte que
que que la façon
dont dont le progrès dont la croissance
fonctionne créer C cré ces disparités
et il faut pas laisser les gens faut pas
les laisser alors ça peut être
conjoncturel avec l'inflation qui existe
qui est née entre autre de la de la
guerre en Ukraine mais temporairement il
faut il faut aider est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut aider aussi par des
chèqus alimentaires est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter les salaires qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous ça je
je n'irai pas sur sur ce terrain là de
de d'avoir des solutions vraiment
précise au niveau économique je vais
aller voir notre ministre de l'Économie
lui dire dit donc il faud rit faire ça
parce que sinon euh parce que sinon ça
va pas marcher non je pense je crois
qu'il y a il faut développer un un
sentiment de solidarité et que même ne
serait-ce que si les gens qui sont dans
cette dans cette précarité
sentaiit que ils sont pris en compte que
l'état donne 10 des mots des mots qui
qui qui ne paraissent pas forcément
vains des mots qui sont euh des des des
mots euh oui de de de de compréhension
des des l'envie de de faire des
propositions au moins l'envie de faire
des propositions de faire des
consultations de de de de de de
rencontrer de rencontrer ces bénévoles
de rencontrer les gens de se dire tiens
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer dites-nous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut améliorer pour pour euh pour pour
le sort de ces gens-là aujourd'hui ce ce
dialogue là n'existe plus qu'on est trop
individualiste peut-être oui de façon
générale on a on a parce que il faut pas
non plus que l'État soit considéré comme
comme comme la
comme il y a déjà il y a déjà la
sécurité sociale il y a déjà beaucoup de
choses que que que pour lequel l'État
vient intervenir dans dans la solidarité
pour pour aider les gens qui sont
malalade que qui peuvent pas aller au
travail enfin il y a il y a il y a des
il y a des des tas de il y a des il y a
des il y a des déjà l'État est déjà pas
mal mais je pense aussi que il on est
dans une démocratie on est ici à
l'Assemblée
nationale ça veut dire qu'il faut que
les gens se sentent
responsables démocratie c'est pas
uniquement on va voter de temps en temps
pour n'importe qui pour n'importe quoi
et surtout pour n'importe qui de plus en
plus donc euh donc il
faut il faut simplement il faut aussi se
sentir responsable donc oui avoir
organisé des choses à niveau de l'État
pour que pour que des gens qui justement
se sentent responsables puissent être
considérer écouter dans leur
solution ça a été fait sur des problèmes
dit de comme sur l'écologie et tout ça
on fait des réunions on discute et on
essaie de trouver des conventions
convtion et bien pour oui pour résoudre
ces problèmesl de de de de précarité de
pauvreté je suis certain que si on on
fait des conventions tout autour de la
table je pense qu'on doit trouver des
solutions vous Jean-Pierre Daroussin
vous êtes centrair plutôt un homme de
gauche je dirais est-ce que vous trouvez
que la gauche aujourd'hui elle est
présente sur ces sujets là et qu'elle
est bien
représentée la
gauche la gauche c'est compliqué parce
que la la la gauche elle est elle s'est
trahi elle-même pendant toutes ces
derniers temps parce que elle a fait le
le jeu de ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le la la prédominance de la
croissance et de la prédominance de la
recherche du du bonheur à travers
l'économie à travers la la la à travers
le développement la gauche elle a
contribué au fait qu'on fasse pousser de
l'argent sur des terrains où il était
pas où il était pas normal de faire
pousser de l'argent on a mis des engrais
on a mis des des des des des pesticides
là pour faire pousser de l'argent et euh
et et et et et on en a fait pousser pas
mal et donc les gens qui qui qui étaient
historiquement dans une sensibilité de
gauche se sont quand même sentis trahis
de de de de ça c'est votre cas oui oui
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est mon cas
bon allez on va passer au dessert si
vous le voulez bien c'est le péché
mignonoui et Brigitte avec une
gourmandise qui a le vent en poupe une
Pavlova du nom d'une danseuse russe Anna
Pavlova star dans les années 20 il
s'agit d'un dessert comme on le voit
constitué d'une meringue italienne
surmontée de crème fouettée avec des
fruits des fruits rouges en l'occurrence
là aujourd'hui c'est de la mangue la
petite histoire à vérifier dit que cette
pâtisserie aurait été créée lors d'une
tournée de cette fameuse Pavlova en
Océanie pour l'anecdote deux pays
l'Australie et la Nouvelle-Zélande se
revendiqueent la paternité de ce dessert
qui plaît à notre invité vous avez
découvert la pavlova ou Jean-Pierre
d'oussin alors moi je je vais en
Australie non non je je vais aller ni
l'un ni l'autre je ne suis jamais allé
aussi
non mais à
Marseille mais alors moi je je vais
certainement contredire l'origine de la
pablov mais quand c'est aussi une une
petite madeleine pour moi parce que
c'était un un
dessert qui était mon dessert préféré
quand j'étais gamin mais à l'époque on
appelait ça la Polonaise d'accord on
appelait ça la polonaise et ça
s'appelait pas la pavlova et puis la
Polonaise ça a disparu j'en trouvais
plus dans les dans les pâtisseries dans
les boulangeries je trouvais plus de
et puis il y a quelques années est
revenu la pablova alors
c'est et est à votre goût et
c'est c'està-d c'est exactement la même
la même chose que la Polonaise que je
mangeais quand j'étais quand j'étais
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP